Good morning John.
First, I cannot believe it's been five years since TFIOS.
Life keeps passing us by.
Second, I'm sorry to hear about your rib. I have no idea what that must feel like.
And I hope I never find out.
And third, today I want to talk about happiness
because we humans are not particularly
good at knowing what makes us happy,
so sometimes we have to be told.
and of the happiness increasing strategies that I hear about,
they almost all seem to be either obvious,
not well supported by science,
difficult to implement, or to only produce short term gains in happiness, not long term.
But there is one thing that I found that hits the the golden trifecta here.
It has measurable, significant, dose dependent peer reviewed impact.
It's both actionable and passive, meaning that it's
something that a lot of people can do and once you do it it's hard to undo
and it's non intuitive, meaning it actually helps to be told because it's not obvious.
Your commute to work is a magnificent source
of unhappiness, unpleasantness, stress, and even unhealthiness.
The commute is rated by most workers as the least pleasant thing that they do everyday.
Though we are making Dear Hank and John with those people in mind,
hopefully it's helping.
The happiest commuters commute by bicycle
the least happy commute alone, in a vehicle by themselves
which is, of course, by far the most common way that we commute.
Commutes over one hour are linked not just to stress, but to chronic pain and to high cholesterol.
People with long commutes are also less likely to have time for physical leisure, and on average spend less
time with friends. We often do not consider the magnitude of impact that our commute will have
on our lives when we're making big decisions
like where we will work and where we will live.
Moving closer to work even if it means living in a smaller or more expensive or both place
is often the far better decision for personal happiness,
even though the effects of the larger house or the more money or the better job
seem far more present in our minds.
The blankness of the commute, this lost time, it's not easy for our minds to consider.
According to one study, freeing up an hour long commute was the same happiness gain as going
from a $60,000 a year job to a $100,000 a year job.
People with the longest commutes in one study
were found to have the least amount of satisfaction with their lives.
While owning a home or moving to a bigger place
has been found to have no long-term impact on average happiness.
Of course the ability to choose a longer commute is a luxury in itself,
a luxury that is not available to everyone. Which is why it's also important
that we allow our cities to grow in more dense ways. And that those who live in established neighbourhoods
that are close to where people work don't fight to prohibit dense developement, which in the course of
trying to protect the character of our neighbourhoods we often do. If there's no new inventory nearby the jobs,
there will always have to be more commuting into the jobs. Which is bad for the environment, but it's also bad
for the people who have to drive 90 minutes each way to work. Research continually indicates that happiness is
not about what we have but about what we do with the individual minutes and hours and days of our lives.
And that can be, surprisingly, hugely affected by the decisions that we make in urban planning and how we
build our cities. And also the individual decisions that individual people make, often using faulty decison
making processes that our brains aren't really designed for. So just remember that, on average, spending
upwards of 10% of your waking hours alone in a car, even if you do have the company of Dear Hank and John,
should be avoided if it can be. John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
We're doing a thing at DFTBA called the Awesome Socks Club. I'm just a huge fan of weird socks. And I can do
this with my legs, I'm flexible, yeah. Can I get them both up there? I can! So these are the socks, these are the
first ones, the DFTBA Awesome Socks Club will deliver a new pair or socks to you every single month. You won't
know what they're gonna look like until they arrive, though. But they're gonna be weird.